I've been playing this character for six
years and I feel like I'm constantly
learning new things about her Torrey
DeVitto is spilling Pretty Little Liars
a season seven secrets and taking us
into the mysterious mind of Melissa
Hastings do you feel like she is a
villain or do you feel like she's a hero
I think she has good intentions just
kind of goes about things the wrong way
sometimes she was a stranger and I
buried her alive I mean that's the
example right there I mean if you want
to protect your sister I think that's so
admirable and great but you don't have
to bury someone alive to do it but then
since she did that do you think that
she's capable of having killed Charlotte
I think on this show especially
anything's possible
this is suitcase is broken there's a
part missing that's metal Hollow and cut
with a rectangle in the end what was the
deal with the the suitcase handle that's
a good question
I think you know a lot of times - I
think they set things up so that you get
distracted from what could potentially
be the truth right there this show is
like a jigsaw puzzle you know I mean
you're constantly trying to put it
together and the pieces just don't get
it let's talk about Melissa and
Spencer's relationship a little bit I'm
not jealous it's not a sisterly
relationship that I would particularly
want in my family but you know at the
end of the day it's as crazy as
everything is they have had each other's
backs in very odd pseudo aggressive ways
I personally don't think she's trying to
do her harm I mean like I said I could
always change - but when it comes to
Spencer's love life there's still some
resentment on Melissa's end
she's right now kind of dating Caleb but
everybody loves her with Toby Melissa
said you know shopping out of other
people's cards are you that is very true
I can't help but feel bitter for Melissa
because it is it's the cause of concern
she's always dating other people's
boyfriends do you want her to get back
together with Toby though yeah I think
they're a good relationship I like that
one I've
vote for them Tories had a busy month as
she also stars on Chicago med and she's
the ambassador of philosophies hoping
grace initiative which supports mental
health awareness I have had anxiety as
far as I can remember I feel like
there's a lot of shame that goes
involved that's involved with people you
know admitting that they have anxiety
and it doesn't take away from your power
in the workplace or your power as a
person or as a woman or as a man so I
just think people should feel
comfortable about talking about it it's
totally okay